now from Dartmouth College in Hanover
New Hampshire author David vise
discusses his new book the bureau in the
mall it's about former FBI agent and
accused spy Robert handsome
during this hour-long event the author
details mr. Hamptons rise through the
FBI and what eventually led him to work
as a double agent for the Soviet Union
good afternoon hi I'm Barry Sher Provost
of Dartmouth College I'm very pleased to
walk you to welcome you to the third of
six lectures in the Montgomery endowment
series entitled intelligence the need to
know initiated by Bob Wilson class of 63
this series is designed to bring an
array of experts to the Dartmouth
community to examine intelligence issues
which were brought to the nation's keen
attention by the tragic events of
September 11th the lectures will
continue to be offered each Tuesday
through February 26 here in Filene
auditorium this series is made possible
through the generosity of Kenneth
Montgomery class of 25 and his wife Haro
who created and funded the endowment in
1978 so that Dartmouth could bring
outstanding individuals to campus
throughout the years these guests have
enriched the opportunities already
available at the college by
complementing the regular curricular
offerings of the institution they have
come not only from the academic world
but from the non-academic spheres as
well we're indebted to the Montgomerys
for initiating this endowment we have
heard in previous talks from mark direct
former officer in the CIA and james
Woolsey former director of the Central
Intelligence Agency today's speaker is
David vice a graduate of the University
of Pennsylvania he has an MBA from the
Wharton School in an honorary doctorate
of literary letters from Cumberland
University he also studied at the London
School of Economics vice was a
successful Wall Street investment banker
at Goldman Sachs & Company when he
decided that he wanted to pursue a
career in something he loved journalism
it is reported that during an interview
at The Wall Street Journal with Howard
Simons and Ben Bradley Simon Simon said
now wait a minute let me get this
straight
you have your MBA or a successful banker
in Wall Street and you want to become a
journalist do your parents know what
you're doing it's not clear whether or
not they did but in any case it turned
out to be a good move
he is recipient of numerous honors and
awards for his journalistic skills
covering Wall Street and the financial
world including the Pulitzer Prize in
1994 for part series the man from Wall
Street
Jon Chad's reign at the SEC he received
numerous awards from the Maryland
Delaware DC Press Association for
coverage of the nation's capital
city and other groundbreaking journalism
he currently covers the FBI and the
Justice Department mr. Vyse is most
recent success his book entitled the
bureau and the mall hit number five and
he amazon.com bestseller lists his first
week of release and is now in a New York
Times best seller list
he'll be made into a movie by Jerry
Bruckheimer films and Disney's
touchstone pictures in this exciting
book David vise writes that the FBI was
warned eleven years ago that agent
Robert Hansen might be spying for the
Russians but the bureau failed to
investigate for nearly a decade it was a
gargantuan blunder of vice world in
describing one of the most damaging
espionage cases in US history in a live
online interview of I said that Hansen
was never given a lie-detector test or
subjected to psychological examination
during his 25 year FBI career in the
aftermath of his case
the FBI has begun the process of
implementing tighter screening
procedures not only when agents are
hired and trained but during their
careers they have begun with polygraphs
the FBI resisted implementing these
measures for fear of breaking the bonds
of loyalty and Trust with a new bureau
let us hope that the information he
shares with us today about the FBI will
be more encouraging as he speaks on the
secret story is a modern FBI in America
silent war please join me in welcoming
David vice
thank you very much for that very
generous introduction it's a pleasure to
be here as part of this lecture series
it's great to be back at the last time I
was here Dartmouth was quite a number of
years ago I was working on Wall Street
and I flew up on a very very icy cold
day to try to see if I could convince a
few seniors here to come to work at
Goldman Sachs and I was in completely
and totally unsuccessful that day so my
hope is that all of you who are here
today will help me feel better about
Hannover and better about Dartmouth
because if you don't purchase some
copies of the Bureau on the mole here I
have to take all these back with me and
my small backpack to Washington so I'm
counting on you after this lecture to
help me out where were you on September
11th when you heard the news
where were you were you at home will you
at work were you talking to a friend
what was the first thought that came to
your mind on September 11th who did you
call
who did you email what did you think
about did you wonder if someone you knew
or someone you loved might have been
killed in that disaster September 11th a
day that none of us will ever forget a
horrors reach this shore a day for many
Americans
not unlike December 7th 1941 when Pearl
Harbor was bombed people remember that
day too and where they were when they
first heard the news both I submit to
you today December 7th 1941 and
September 11th 2001
represent
colossal intelligence failures on the
part of the United States of America in
1941 after the Japanese attack on Pearl
Harbor the Congress of the United States
launched a series of hearings very
shortly after that surprise attack to
determine what went wrong why had the
United States been taken by surprise in
that attack what happened in the
aftermath of the terrorist bombing on
September 11th no such thing has
occurred in Washington still to this day
people are reluctant politicians are
reluctant to question administration
officials to raise any questions
publicly not only about the campaign
taking place militarily in Afghanistan
but about why the United States was
taken by surprise not a hearing not a
tough statement no one wishes to journey
there what's changed what happened why
did in the United States know what was
coming the greatest and most powerful
nation on this earth taken by surprise
in a ruthless but clever and terrible
attack on the Pentagon World Trade
Center and in Pennsylvania where some
courageous passengers aboard an aircraft
prevented another plane from landing in
Washington and causing further bloodshed
inside the Federal Bureau of
Investigation inside its nerve center
known as Sai Ock
the strategic information Operations
Center there is a room it's smaller than
this room and 24 hours a day seven days
a week
under FBI director Louis Freeh a group
of people in that room monitored Osama
bin Laden around-the-clock no break in
the action their round-the-clock all day
all night day night weekend poster on
the wall of that room Osama bin Laden
the face of evil so how is it possible
then given the fact that preventing a
terrorist act not just responding to one
but preventing a terrorist attack on
these United States how is it possible
then that we were taken by surprise
why has this tragedy of September 11th
become such a grave intelligence failure
and why is it today that we are living
with its aftermath some months before
September 11th I had begun covering the
Justice Department and the Federal
Bureau of Investigation for The
Washington Post and I was on the beat
for about a year and a half when a story
broke and actually was about one year
ago now was February 2001 and the story
was about a man named Robert Phillip
Anson married six children goes to
church every morning confession on a
regular basis
waved the flag on the 4th of July a 25
year veteran of the FBI who's secretly
unknown to his family unknown to his
friends and unknown to the director of
the FBI had been spying for the Russians
giving up the most sensitive
intelligence secrets ever sold by a mole
within the bureau how could this be
after all FBI director Louis Freeh is a
very very bright man and a solid FBI guy
he went to the same church as Robert
Hansen their children attended the same
school friends in the same community
both at the bureau both live in Northern
Virginia nobody had a clue why well for
one thing Robert Hansen was a very very
devilishly clever spy even the Russians
imagine this for the 20 year time span
that he was conducting espionage even
the Russians never knew his name he
concealed his identity for 20 years he
was shrewd enough and bright enough to
hand pick the person who would be his
handler in the Russian embassy in
Washington a man named victor cherkashin
he was careful enough to spy and to
refrain from spying on several occasions
during the period from 1979 until his
arrest in February of last year he had
self-discipline he had a motive
and he was in the words of one former
FBI director the intelligence
community's equivalent of a 500 year
flood this is a man who sold the
Russians the super secret plan for how
the United States would operate where
the president would go where the vice
president would go where the Congress
would go where other top ranking federal
officials would go in the event of a
nuclear first-strike the continuity of
government plan that Robert Hansen sold
to the Soviet Union quite literally
increased the risk of nuclear war
because the Russians believed that they
could prevail in such an attack for a
number of years a 500 million dollar spy
tunnel underneath the Russian embassy in
Washington DC built the taxpayer expense
a clandestine operation the joint work
of the FBI and the National Security
Agency compromised by Hansen instead of
being a great source of intelligence the
Russians used that spy tunnel as part of
a disinformation campaign and it gets
more personal too in his very first
communication with Viktor Chirk kashin
Robert Hansen revealed the identities of
a number of Russians who had secretly
been recruited by the United States to
provide us with intelligence called back
to Russia under false pretenses they
were put to death a bullet to the back
of the head in Lubyanka prison the
gravity and the breath and the prolific
nature of his spying has no parallel in
this nation's history we're talking
about a man with the access at the
highest levels of security clearance and
with the computer skills
as well who sold secrets not only from
the FBI but who gave up secrets from the
National Security Agency the CIA the
White House National Security Council
and the Defense Intelligence Agency at
the Pentagon no one in American history
has ever done anything quite like this
when I first began covering this story
and I read the affidavit in the case I
immediately saw a movie in my head
after all the story played out largely
in Washington Hansen refused all Russian
requests to travel abroad to ever meet
face to face with his handler or others
he preferred a method that was very
crude and simple and brilliant all at
once he would leave information under
foot bridges in parks near his home in
Northern Virginia signal the Russians
with masking tape they would pick up the
information which he left in black hefty
garbage bags and they would pay him in
cash six hundred thousand dollars in
cash over about 20 years and diamonds
but this wasn't really about money sure
money may have been a trigger money may
have been a way of keeping score this
was about something else Robert Hansen
was a man who from his earliest days as
a child felt the very rough hand of his
father he was an abused child whose
father a Chicago policeman himself
constantly
put his son down emotionally if not
physically when young Bob as a teenager
went to get his driver's license his
father actually bribed the driving
instructor in Chicago to flunk his son a
remarkable act and Bob learned about it
so his feelings of alienation began as a
young man and grew over time after he
joined the Chicago Police Force he
became a member of a secret unit c5
investigating corrupt cops in his mind
who was the corrupt cop his father he
went on to become an agent with the FBI
he held the FBI in the greatest of
esteem he loved J Edgar Hoover anything
and everything about him that he knew a
strong leader someone who didn't while
someone who didn't give in to the
bureaucracy but Robert Hansen felt the
FBI didn't recognize his talents and
skills he lacked interpersonal skills
that would have enabled him perhaps with
his genius to rise through the ranks to
a senior level position and so he felt
frustrated in his career he dressed in
black like Hoover behind his back they
called him dr. death they called him the
mortician these were his colleagues at
the FBI but they never suspected what he
was up to several years after joining
the FBI Hansen made his way over to
Russian intelligence he had always been
fascinated since childhood by all things
clandestine and now opportunity
presented itself for the first time
20 years ago
Bonnie Hansen Robert Hansen's wife
walked in and saw he became very nervous
covered up the papers that he had in
front of him she thought maybe he was
writing a love letter to another woman
that wasn't what was happening at all in
fact he was selling secrets to Soviet
military intelligence but he told Bonnie
when she asked that he was actually
tricking the Russians selling them
worthless information in exchange for
$20,000 in cash Bonnie said him doesn't
sound good to me
I think we need to go see a priest and
so they did they went to see a man named
father Booker le his initial instinct
was you know you ought to turn yourself
in this is a crime you've committed I
can't decide here but they asked the
priest to consider and reconsider what
it is he would direct them to do Bonnie
was a very religious woman devout
Catholic member of Opus Dei a very
strict movement within the Catholic
Church and so when father Booker le came
back and said what you need to do is
give that $20,000 to the Charities of
Mother Teresa and promise you'll never
do this again
and seek forgiveness everything will be
okay and that's what Hansen did promised
never to do it again not the first time
he'd broken a promise in fact one week
into his marriage he broke a vow he'd
made only days earlier his wife got a
phone call from another woman in Chicago
saying he really wanted to marry me not
you and so she confronted her husband
and he said I made a mistake I'll never
do it again I'll never do it again
Robert Hanssen is emblematic of a
certain breed of person who can live
with unbelievable conflict in life
something I ventured to say not one of
us in this room could do he developed
and his mind developed in such a way
that he compartmentalized all these
things that were occurring at the
extreme how can you be the father of six
children a devoted spouse a man who
waves a flag on the fourth of July and
simultaneously secretly spy for the
Russians while you're working for the
FBI post erotic stories about your
relationship with your wife on the
internet and even do something that is
unspeakable something I discovered in
the course of reporting the bureau on
the mole place a spy camera in your own
bedroom in your own bedroom so that your
best friend could watch while you and
your wife have sex I'm not making this
up this really occurred and I think the
most shocking thing the most shocking
thing I learned in the course of
reporting the bureau in the mall was
that in 1990 an FBI agent by the name of
Mark walk still an agent with the bureau
in Chicago became suspicious
he was Robert Hansen's still is Robert
Hansen's brother-in-law and he learned
that there were thousands of dollars in
cash at the Hansons home in Northern
Virginia
he knew that Robert Hansen worked Soviet
counterintelligence he knew you couldn't
have that kind of cash around on a g-man
salary mark walk was torn imagine
imagine put yourself in his place for a
moment are you loyal to family do you
tell your sister what it is you found
are you loyal to country are you loyal
to the bureau what do you do
mark walk made the hard choice he went
to his superiors at the FBI and he said
I believe you need to open an
investigation into espionage on behalf
of the Soviet Union carried out by
Robert Hansen never told Bonnie but he
told his bosses at the bureau the
information was passed from the Chicago
field office of the FBI headquarters in
Washington there's a very short chapter
in the bureau on the mall it's called
the FBI's blunder unfortunately I think
you know why the bureau failed to follow
up on that information didn't come in
through an 800 number it didn't come in
through an anonymous tip Robert Hansen's
own brother-in-law turned him in in 1990
and the bureau dropped the ball
unfortunately and it is I'm sorry to say
somewhat reminiscent of what happened
prior to September 11th when information
came in from Minneapolis to FBI
headquarters that there were some people
seemed rather suspicious because they
wanted to learn how to fly planes
but they didn't want to learn how to
take off her land wasn't clear what to
do with that information either
one right after September 11th Boni
Hansen was aghast she was mortified like
the rest of us she was very upset about
what occurred but unlike the rest of
this she feared that her husband would
be blamed for what happened on September
11th and why was that the case according
to US intelligence had bonny knew this a
software program that Robert Hansen sold
to the Soviet Union was subsequently
taken and sold by an individual Russian
to al Qaeda the terrorist network of
Osama bin Laden and according to US
intelligence the possession of that
software facilitated Osama bin Laden's
ability to evade detection by the United
States bonny feared that her husband
would be blamed for the loss of life on
September 11th the FBI called her to say
this was a complex event there are many
facets to it you don't need to spend any
more sleepless nights than you already
have
over the terrible breaches your husband
has caused directly we're not going to
publicly blame Robert Hansen for what
has happened here
so then I want to tell you for just a
moment sort of the story behind the
story when this story broke and I
reported on it for The Washington Post
and I saw that movie in my head I had
said to my wife for years gee I'd like
to be involved in making a movie someday
when we walked out of out of the theater
she would laugh maybe and I knew this
was it this seemed to me to be a story
of character of treachery of
international proportion of global
dimension and finally a story of family
and the dynamics of what occurs when one
man trays his children his wife and his
country and so I asked our 13 year old
daughter Lisa because I was very busy
covering this story for the Washington
Post
I said Lisa I need for you to burn a CD
for me please I need some really good
music because I think it's about time
for me to pull a couple of all-nighters
and I didn't know if I could stay up
through the night myself without at
least a little music to listen to
so Lisa did it I popped the CD in and I
pulled two all-nighters wrote a proposal
for a movie sent it to Hollywood and
before I knew what happened I had sold
the rights to make a movie based on a
book I hadn't written without a
publisher
and you say oh so I then turned around
and began to look for a publisher who
might be interested in this
unfortunately I work at a great
newspaper The Washington Post that's
supportive of people taking time to dig
into important stories to go beyond the
Daily News and take things to the next
level but when I went to the publishing
community in New York it seemed that all
the publishers had long time tables in
mind so if you turn in a manuscript
we'll publish a book in a year 18 months
whatever yeah there's a couple of other
books that have been signed up on this
subject already yeah we're not so sure
maybe yes maybe now and at the time I
became very frustrated because I knew I
wanted to do my best I didn't want to
compromise quality I didn't want to
compromise fairness or accuracy
something I pledged to everyone whether
it's a newspaper reporting or in writing
a book and my test for fairness and
accuracy is what I feel a story were
fair if it were written about me based
on what I know I asked my colleague and
mentor at the Washington Post Bob
Woodward I said what's the fastest simon
and schuster ever turned around one of
your books knowing of course that I'm
not Bob Woodward and he said about three
to four months so I suggested to the
literary agent that he find someone who
was willing to publish a book in about
three or four months and fortunately
there is one publisher left among the
majors only one in New York that is not
part of the large conglomerate and that
publishers Grove Atlantic Atlantic
Monthly press and they said sure we'll
we'll turn it around if you can produce
this book but we want to put something
special in the contract hmm wonder what
that is
I said if you don't turn in a manuscript
that's completely acceptable to us by
this fixed date in September
you have to give the entire advance back
all the money back and that's it you
never see it again
well the agent handling this became very
concerned he said to me this is
unreasonable in writing they're only
willing to commit to publishing it
within one year they want you to give
all the money back if you don't report
and write this story in for five months
and they're saying they're going to turn
it around in that amount of time he said
I guess it's a deal breaker I said no I
said if they're crazy enough that
somebody to give back their entire
advance under those circumstances that
tells me they're really serious about
publishing this book so I went forward
and dug into the story worked 18 hours a
day with the help of two wonderful
research assistants and a very
supportive wife and three children
and took that room on the third floor of
our house that we'd turn into a nice
playroom for the kids and made it into
the Robert Hanssen Bureau on the mold
room and we began to dig and dig and dig
and one thing led to another and finally
I submitted the manuscript just after
September 11th publisher had made a
commitment I had made a commitment the
fellow who was the hands-on editor had
made a commitment only he was stuck in
London and then stuck in Newfoundland
and then back in London so I had nowhere
to turn in the manuscript I said what
are we going to do we got to keep moving
here if we're going to get this book out
I want to make sure the book is out in
time for Hanson scheduled sentencing in
January so we said well why don't you
email it one chapter at a time to me
here in London at Canongate books the
editor-in-chief of canongate will then
download this one chapter at a time
print it out and give me a copy so
that's what we did
and my good fortune then the process of
doing that the editor Canongate took a
look at this and said I want to publish
this in Great Britain and so the book is
is being published around the world not
only in the United States
and Robert Hanssen himself is now in the
process of being debriefed the events of
September 11th caused his sentencing to
be rescheduled from January until this
May he's been questioned by FBI CIA and
those from other intelligence agencies
that have a direct interest in this
matter he is still a man who can hide in
plain sight he is still man who is a
master manipulator without appearing to
ever manipulate anyone at all his wife
upon reading some of the correspondence
he'd had with the Russians asked him did
you really mean it
when you wrote to them and you asked for
an escape plan to Moscow were you really
going to leave me and he said no no no
no that was just to make them feel like
I was a real spy and hear everything
that's love to me you everything that's
life to me without you Bonnie there'd be
no reason for me to go on living and
Bonnie Hanson accepted that as well as
her husband's apology she prays for his
soul every day she visits him and her
children as you might imagine with six
ranging in age from a daughter in high
school to a daughter with children of
her own who's in her 30s have their own
discussion and debate going on about all
of this what does it mean for their
family what does it mean for their
children what does it mean for their
children's children
Robert Hanssen as a young man had a role
model and an idol kim Philby kim Philby
was a british spy mi6 ultimately
defected to Moscow more typically we
hear about someone who wants to grow up
and be Michael Jordan or the next great
rock star but here was a man who grew up
as a boy actually had a spy as role
model 25 years at the FBI not a single
polygraph test the FBI was looking for a
mole along with the CIA
from 19 from the mid-1990s forward
knowing with great certainty that there
was another mole out there after alder
James was arrested Ames a CIA spy for
the Russians handled by the same man
Viktor sure cashing such your cash in
had one spy over it Langley one spy
inside the bureau and it was very clear
after alder James arrest that there was
another mole because Ames knew nothing
about certain things that US
intelligence had learned the Russians
knew so the hunt began the hunt for the
mole and it went on and on the CIA in
the aftermath of the Aldrich Ames case
instituted mandatory polygraph testing
on a regular basis for all employees the
FBI on the other hand for a variety of
reasons resisted polygraphs except for
newly hired employees so the new
recruits at Quantico at the lowest level
of security clearance go through
physical examination psychological
examination polygraph and the rest but
the higher and higher Robert Hansen went
in the FBI nobody ever asked him any
questions that he had to answer under
oath or with a polygraph that might have
detected something now granted
polygraphs are not foolproof people beat
polygraphs all the time polygraphs
aren't even admissible in many legal
situations but like a blinking yellow
light polygraphs do serve as a deterrent
to espionage might make somebody stop
and think twice so the FBI in the
aftermath of the Hanson case among other
things has begun to polygraph on a
regular basis its employees something
that had been strongly resisted in part
because the FBI is a very solid
organization which much like a
fraternity is built on trust an FBI
director Louis Freeh was concerned that
introducing polygraphs might hurt that
culture of trust in addition there was a
problem that had occurred at the CIA
when they began polygraphing people it
turned out they asked them questions
about their personal lives and their
work lives the needle was very steady
when they asked them about their work
lives but when they asked them about
their personal lives the needle went
kind of haywire a lot of people
apparently didn't tell the truth when
they were asked questions about their
personal lives and so a lot of valuable
CIA operatives because of unresolved
ambiguities on polygraphs
now sit taxpayer expense and Langley
unable to work for the CIA Louis Freeh
didn't want the same thing to happen to
the FBI so when the FBI ultimately did
in the aftermath of the Hanson case
begin polygraphing employees the bureau
only went so far on the personal side
stuck to the work stuff more closely
let's remember that it would have been
very easy for Robert Hanssen to go on
spying undetected for a longer period of
time if the FBI had not run what in the
end under Louie fries direction was a
very difficult operation to nail the
mole there were some misfires to be sure
there was one employee at the CIA who
was accused of being the mole whose
daughter who also worked at the CIA was
taken into a room she was shown a map we
know your father's the mole she was told
by her interrogators because here's the
map we see where his deaddrop sites are
we know there's been activity in there
we've seen the Russians around there
turned out the CIA agent lived very near
Robert Hansen and like to go jogging
through that park that was his jogging
map and a terrible mistake was made in
that instance but ultimately the CIA in
the fall of 2000 got the original KGB
file on Hansen and turned it over to the
FBI the original documents the Russians
are so good at spying they don't allow
copies of documents to be made that are
such a sensitive nature I think a
government built on deception breeds
good spies brilliant spies in some ways
be very difficult for the United States
ever to run a spy for 20 years the way
the Russians did Hansen and not know his
identity not give in to that normal
human impulse to hide behind the tree
and maybe take a look but remember if
you stuck around to take a look there
was a big risk not just that Hansen
might see but that someone from the FBI
might be following you if the FBI was on
your trail and you're a Russian in
Washington and then the FBI
intelligence expert following you might
see Hansen there blow the whole
operation they cared much more about the
value of the information than they did
about knowing his identity think for a
moment about that that withstood the
collapse of the Berlin Wall the
disintegration of the Soviet Union
economic political and social turmoil
and Hansen resumed a spying in 1999 when
Vladimir Putin came to power in Russia
no coincidence shootin as I'm sure many
of you are aware was a high-ranking KGB
man himself so in the fall of 2000 the
FBI got a file and it still wasn't clear
from that file who Hansen was he had
used aliases in all of his
communications with the Russians Ramon
Garcia was the name he used most often
they also called him b-but Robert Hansen
had forgotten to do one thing he didn't
wear gloves in the cold and the Russians
had saved one of those black hefty
garbage bags CIA got the bag gave it to
the FBI FBI took the fingerprints off
that black garbage bag and identified
Hansen but the bureau still couldn't
move in on Hansen and arrest him what
are you gonna charge him with who you
going to put on the witness stand
nothing but a circumstantial case so the
FBI recalled Hansen from a state
department where he had been detailed
put him into an office told him he was
being promoted and watched him 24 hours
a day seven days a week
cut off his access to sensitive
information bought a house up the block
from Hansen in Vienna watched in there
too and waited until answer
made plans for his next dead drop and on
February 18th 2001 Hanson woke up went
to church with his family same church as
FBI director Louis Freeh they would sit
on opposite sides Hanson's family on the
left side the free family on the right
side he came home after church his
friend Jack Ho shower was there they
chatted outside played frisbee with
their dog named Sunday and a Ford too
long it was time for Jack to go to
Dulles Airport and so Hansen said let me
let me get a few things together Jack
and then I'll take you to the airport
let me put those intelligence documents
together and he handed Jack host shower
a book before he left the house now he
did not hand him the bureau on the mole
because that hadn't been written yet but
he handed him a book by one of his
favorite authors a man by the name of GK
Chesterton
the book was called the man who was
Thursday it's a very very interesting
book the book Hanson identified with
strongly and when he gave that book to
jack ho shower his closest friend his
friend who he had let watch things that
other people shouldn't watch he said
these words things are not always the
way they seem and when the news came out
two days later Jack Ho shower had those
words ringing in his head things are not
always the way they say after he dropped
Jack Ho shower off at Dulles Airport
Hanson went to Fox stone Park in
Northern Virginia he left that hefty
garbage bag full of documents underneath
the footbridge the Russians had left him
$50,000 in $100 bills not far away here
was a man
who truly had a fractured ego seeking
recognition affirmed over and over again
and correspondence by the KGB the
friendly folks at the KGB who wrote to
him and always addressed him with dear
friend dear friend and Hansen left those
documents under the foot bridge and on
his way walking back to the car he was
surrounded by FBI agents who told him to
freeze at FBI headquarters inside Sayaka
was FBI director Louis Freeh inside that
nerve center presiding over the arrest
of Robert Hansen at the moment of his
arrest as they slapped the handcuffs on
Robert Hansen asked a question which to
this day still haunts the FBI he looked
at them and he said what took you so
long what took you so long it's a
remarkable story the bureau on the mall
and what I've tried to do is tell you
the story not only of Robert Hansen in
this book but also the story of FBI
director Louis Freeh an amazing man they
both joined the bureau around the same
time they had so many things in common
yet one became the director the other
became the biggest spy in American
history and their lives were joined
together finally on that day when free
presided over his arrest now all of you
are here today I need your help because
I am now consultant to the movie and I
need to help Hollywood figure out who
plays Louis Freeh and who plays Robert
Hanssen so now all of you here please
consider yourselves consultants to the
consultant because I'm not sure exactly
who ought to play Louie and who ought to
play Hanson challenging part challenging
parts and if you don't have the answer
today please log on to www.nasa.gov
it's a privilege to be here with all of
you today Thanks
I'm especially happy to answer questions
and afterwards again there will be an
opportunity and he'll be signing books
up front I do want to say and since this
is being taped by c-span if you do have
a question when you recognize please
wait until your hand and microphone
before you ask the question thank you so
it was interesting to hear it again did
you say it was the CIA who finally got
the the folder on him
that's correct CIA ready operating in
Moscow right and how did they get it
when I began covering the Justice
Department and the FBI for The
Washington Post
I promised a couple of things to the
folks at the FBI and at justice I said I
would never get in the way of a
legitimate law enforcement operation and
I said that I would never put anyone's
life in danger or give up anything I
knew to be a sensitive national security
secret and this is leading me to where
you think it's leading me next question
it's a great question the details I mean
at the at the most general level I can
tell you that there was a source
developed money changed hands
information was sold
someone took an enormous risk and the
CIA succeeded in getting those original
papers back including actually one tape
recording that was among the documents
and which on a voice enhanced basis also
aided in the confirmation that it was
Robert Hanssen yes um having having read
your series in the Washington Post
it seemed um that Hansen didn't do this
for the Russians he did it almost
against the FBI is that your conclusion
that he was so dissing
franchised I think that this was not
motivated whatsoever by ideology he
didn't do this for the Russians he
didn't do it for the Communists he did
this to be the best spy possible he did
this to get back at his dad to get back
at the FBI he did this to feel like a
player think about this for a moment a
man who feels overlooked a man who's
been put down to t was a kid suddenly
made himself into such an important
player that he was communicating
directly with the head of the KGB that
he was communicating directly with the
head of the KGB at the highest levels of
the Russian government and so he didn't
do it for ideology he didn't do it
because anyone forced him into it he
wasn't recruited he volunteered and yes
an answer to your question he did it in
some ways out of ambition and out of a
drive related to ego he wanted to be
James Bond and he was better than Bond
fascinating story but it leaves me more
uncomfortable than ever how what took
them so long you know you started you
talked about the that there was
information known about September 11th
etc and yet it seemed like nobody
everyone was asleep I mean why is that
the case and has it changed or don't you
know well it's it's I think it's the
question on the minds of every American
you know do we really know
do we know where Osama bin Laden is now
no we don't apparently if public
officials are telling us the truth and
there's no reason to disbelieve them I
think that the events in the Hanson case
reflect the fact that the bureau had
something of a hollow middle and still
does unfortunately what do I mean by
that terrific new recruits hungry young
talent joining the FBI extraordinarily
bright committed people at the top of
the FBI running various divisions but in
between a great deal of inexperience
and in the middle management layers the
FBI does not have as deep a bench as it
wishes it did and the result of that is
that the FBI doesn't always know what it
knows people are fond of saying well
it's the unknown unknown you can't plan
for the unknown unknown the hard part is
the Bureau doesn't always know what it
knows because knowledge requires
analysis judgment language specialists
and more
so I think that all of the resources of
this government in the aftermath of this
tragedy and of this country are being
devoted to trying to prevent anything
from this like this from ever occurring
again but it's also clear that reform is
needed and that was clear even before
September 11th and FBI director fre was
in the midst of trying to make changes
FBI director Muller is doing the same
now others in the intelligence community
share the sentiment there is a
tremendous commitment I think by a very
experienced enable administration to do
everything in its power but in the end
human intelligence in terms of obtaining
information and developing informants
and human intelligence in terms of
analyzing information ultimately is the
key to unlocking the door that lets you
prevent these types of acts
now the FBI does a very good job of
preventing a lot of activity that you
never hear about kind of like the
lawyers who say well the best case is
the ones that never made it to trial or
that the public never heard about so
there is work that goes on behind the
scenes that around the millennium you
remember the millennium everyone was
afraid at the Millennium that something
terrible is going to happen the FBI
working with other federal agencies and
working with law enforcement
intelligence around the world did an
outstanding job in thwarting a number of
planned attacks in connection with the
Millennium so I think you have to
recognize that this terrorist plot that
occurred exceeded the expectations of
its perpetrators and it is very very
difficult I think for people in
positions of leadership to do anything
to this day
but focus on trying to prevent something
like that again the reality remains that
the FBI is outstanding at investigating
crimes and other problems after they
occur but not before prior to September
11th the FBI which had developed a
global network under Louis Freeh the FBI
has had built a permanent presence which
it has now in over 40 countries around
the world but the FBI was still trying
at that point to fight terrorism through
the US legal system now the military is
involved and a much more aggressive
approach is being taken and I can only
hope as an American and as a husband and
a father that this approach will succeed
over time and that the kind of resolve
that we've seen after September 11th
will find its way into an improvement in
our intelligence system worldwide I'd
like to know whether anybody in the in
the CIA after the Aldrich Ames case and
in the FBI after the Hanson case have
been disciplined as a result of their
failures most especially regard to the
brother-in-law's information very
interesting question has anybody been
disciplined in the aftermath of the
Hanson case given the disclosure at
prior to publication of the book before
the bureau on the mall came out I let
attorney General John Ashcroft
and senior FBI officials know of course
about a number of the things I
discovered including Mark walks
disclosure in 1990 which the current
leadership was not aware of and so in
the aftermath of publication of the
bureau on the mall the Attorney General
has ordered a special investigation into
what happened to that information at
this point in time that investigation is
incomplete and so it remains to be seen
whether anyone will be disciplined
whether those who were involved or
responsible or even still with the
bureau after all it this was
this was 1990 so in answer to your
question no single individual has been
held directly accountable so far but I
think we have to await the outcome of
this investigation to see what will
happen this one you indicated that
Hansen had sent material I think you
said software to the Russians which
eventually ended up in the hands of
al-qaeda and it may have helped them in
planning for the attack of September
11th can you elaborate on that well I
can tell you that the information I
don't think based on US intelligence the
information that Hansen sold wasn't
utilized directly in the attack but did
over a period of time facilitate bin
Laden's ability to evade and avoid
monitoring by US officials so it
indirect bearing but not no direct cause
and effect I would say I mean let's also
remember the FBI had a room devoted 24
hours a day to watching bin Laden so you
know there are a lot of factors at play
I think here in this in this instance
and you know the the Bureau on the mole
is a book that tells a narrative story I
mean it's a true story it's written like
a novel and it takes you through not
only the lives of Hansen and free but it
takes you through very precisely what
Hansen betrayed what he sold so at the
back of the book there are three
sections that I added as appendices the
first is the betrayals of a spy second
that lists all the things he sold the
second is the emails of a spy and the
third in his own words sexual fantasies
of a spy I've noticed a lot of people
read this book from the back to the
front
hey hey just one last question please
okay and um earlier hearing about the
Hanson case I've been amazed by how much
he knew and wonder how how can you give
us any idea of how many people are at
that level in the FBI I don't think that
there are a dozen people and he was in
the perfect position to carry this out I
don't think there are dozen people who
would have had access to the same mix of
information and also he knew how to
cover his tracks there was one thing
that occurred some years back he told
one of his superiors at the FBI that
this computer system at the bureau was
vulnerable to someone hacking from the
outside who could get classified
information that the FBI had and the
supervisor didn't really listen to him
and Hanson became kind of agitated
because remember he's a man who has a
lot of compartments in his brain and
when he's doing his day job he's trying
to tell the bureau there's a problem so
what did he do he hacked into the
computer himself without asking
permission of a man named Raymond Locke
Ray was in the midst of reviewing a
classified document and putting it
together himself Bob Hansen walked into
his office handed Raymond lock the
document and said see I told you the
system was vulnerable and he said how
did you get this and he said well you
know I knew the system was vulnerable
I've tried to tell people now I've had
to show you that it's vulnerable and
after that as he would go trolling
through FBI electronic archives and
improve information through the CIA the
NSA he through the National Security
Council he could always say well I was
doing it to see if the system was
vulnerable or not so we had a great
cover story
a brilliant spy
clever man of technology and in the end
I think this case will be celebrated in
Russia as one of the greatest
intelligence cooze ever pulled off
because of Russia's ability to break all
of its own rules allowing someone to
volunteer align them to remain anonymous
allowing them to sell secrets for so
many years and so it will be a case
that's taught in the textbooks
schoolchildren in Moscow and while we
have our thriving democracy here and the
Russians have a government built on
deception they're the next generation of
spies there will be born of great
handlers and others and I will guarantee
you that no matter what efforts are made
here spying and the spy game the second
oldest profession known on this planet
will continue thank you very much
thank you
Oh
Dave advises a Pulitzer Prize winning
staff writer for The Washington Post the
bureau in the mall is his first book
that's published by Grove Atlantic you
can visit the books website the bureau
and the mold comm for more information